okay next game for the session let's try
something Charlie different never played
this before here in the Blitz matches
mmm III or C for that let's play C for
trying to get for some reverse tutorial
yeah this is some reversed Sicilian not
sure what what kind of variation may be
a reversed can or something ok can you
can play with d3 moves like this but
sometimes I said pot it's possible and
now this kind of positions to play I'm
just like Bishop d3 this is an idea here
ok I'll try this trying to weaken this
King side a bit maybe go for Bishop to
e4 ok
maybe chicken bishop before just to get
his King a bit a bit away and make f7
unprotected this could be an idea so
somewhere
okay normal move would be a something
like there should be six now then it's a
question how to proceed I interesting
move here it tends to play a five after
all okay let's let's try something
creative here what about h 4f five then
Knight to g5 friends now to f7
now to f7 if he captures a tag with the
pawn king g8 and after the Queen c4
check and and this wins let's say h 4f
595 rook f8 then I'm not sure what i'm
doing the bishop doesn't have a real
good square and what it looks like fun
come let's let's try this let's try this
even if it's completely completely
insane it's just funny
yeah okay fate looks like looks like the
only move I think okay what now take on
c6 and summer doesn't look right
could could I retreat could I retreat as
possible even can you tell me to get a
bit quicker yeah he still does not
threaten to take because I always have
this is annoying check
think I wanted to play on Knight c3 the
idea 95
if he goes Knight a5 I'm i play Queen B
5 or queen a4 not sure k 95 yeah let's
go on what now yeah maybe he's
threatening 95 let's prevent this he
still cannot take okay but this is
nothing move it doesn't do doesn't do
anything still how to to proceed here
would like to open up the bishop s f F
for us completely completely bogus okay
there's no way back I already burned our
bridges here
and this I find surprising somehow maybe
it's got 95 but but I'm not sure I mean
he's six is a nice square for night and
Nige eat Thai morning ok
okay then you could actually take him
mmm I didn't see this at all ok ok this
is lost with 20 seconds on the clock it
was a nice all very nice idea but maybe
I just should have played this faster
check only ideas g6 rogue h7 now I just
what to a half of the Queen just a minor
piece or gay this is a bit it shouldn't
be enough let's let's put it this way
ah this was the idea I seem
unbelievable it's still somewhat tricky
check check
check check white for face okay what it
was it was it was a fun game it was a
fun game Queen age 7 a.m. okay he was
just just in time to protect this Chuck
Chuck i rue cage one rotates one year I
can play rook h1 and it's completely
okay for me isn't it yeah rook h1 it's
even better for white oh my what a silly
game yeah of course this is nuts adjust
them just the Queen down with no idea
but that was it was interesting not sure
this position is son it's really really
weird maybe it is it's bad for white but
it's it's funny funny too funny to play
yeah objectively black should be should
be winning or something but yeah was it
was just a bit too slow maybe I could
have tricked him or something okay
thanks for watching and yeah make sure
to subscribe or leave comments or
questions um also on request further
subjects for videos something else then
then the blitz games I'm glad to do
something else once in a while so just
give me some ideas yeah until the next
game cm